[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are gonna be unpacking
something that is so important
raising children into the world
maximizing our own happiness and our own
potential and then helping bring that to
everyone around us in our community in
the world we have an epic guest to do
this with today Gabrielle to brown
what's up man I'm doing well man thank
you for having me on the show he's been
great and just even chatting before this
yeah it's been super great we've been
talking about so many different aspects
of this conversation and here we are now
actually able to bring it on video to
the audience so holy cow our parenting
intentionally yeah yeah there's a lot of
nuance here and I love how you're
bringing this to the world with happy
it's been a year yeah AJ PPI yeah
helping awesome parents parent
intentionally yep yeah I love the
acronym yeah well you know I think the
acronym in its in and of itself actually
explains all the details that you need
to know it's like well what are we doing
helping who awesome parents because you
are enough to begin with and you're
awesome like good job for getting this
far right hit like how are we helping by
parenting intentionally when all the
time we're anywhere why because of
happiness right so it kind of
encompasses everything both that I'm I
want this message to be about but it's
also a great reminder to myself it's
it's almost like a way of guiding me
back to my own happy
my own set of values that I believe in I
wonder what is sort of you know the most
important aspect of this that you are
teaching me about earlier is kind of the
oxygen mask analogy you gotta really be
able to help yourself and maximize your
own happiness and potential first and
then really be able to help someone else
like your child right yeah that's I
think the core of the message is to
really reflect on what it is that you
truly value and then to really be more
intentional about designing your life in
alignment with those values the kid
ultimately learns from how it is that
your being in the world and not
necessarily based on what you say right
you know so yeah okay so this is this
has been passed down from Picasso over
time this into this intentionality and
even prior to that too is just the
intentionality of retaining the child
through adulthood retaining that
childhood like curiosity love essence
passion curiosity etc and we kind of
lose that perception over time a lot of
that is the pressures of this
socio-economic and political machinery
of society yeah and so if a parent loses
their relationship with that inner
curiosity inner child then it's hard for
them to keep it with the child that they
have right and it's really hard to be
empathetic and have compassion for your
kid and what they might be going through
because like I was saying before you
know childhood is inherently traumatic
right we're very vulnerable and
impressionable and insecure about a lot
of things and over time
you know the more of these things kind
of pile up on us we're just thinking I I
just want to get out of this place I
want to grow up I don't wanna have to
deal with this anymore and I think like
you're saying sort of these
socio-economic burdens that we have and
conditioning on society about who we
should be and not necessarily who we
feel like we must be as individuals yeah
you you lose sense of that inner
curiosity and and really what makes me
me you know it's it's good to be
different and I think another way of
saying that is the the system is
designed to take away your sense of self
and your agency right and you know that
is the case basically as as early as
we're able to like really receive
information and it's reinforced in
things like the education system right
you know you're being compared against
all of your peers it's a it's a
competition and the competition is based
on these things that we can objectively
quantify about you being smart in this
one particular way right and it requires
lots of memorization and you know
regurgitating information and failing is
the worst possible thing that you can do
and if you don't learn in this
particular way sorry you know here how
to luck right and so you know sorta as a
result of that you look at the way that
technology is designed right these kids
when is it that they actually feel like
they have agency because their parents
are telling them what to do their
teachers are telling them what to do
coaches are telling them what to do
society is telling them what to do
well when I'm on this device I have this
perception of agency right I feel like
everything that I'm doing here is like
my decision I'm making it right I can
connect with my friends
I had to play a bunch of games I can
learn about a whole bunch of stuff that
I never would have otherwise learned
about well if I don't really develop a
strong sense of self and what it is that
I value well you know I'm gonna get
validation from how many likes my
picture got on it because everyone wants
to be cool and fit in and belonged to
something much bigger than themselves
and you know these kids get the message
that doing what's popular is cool and
you know as cliche it is as it is being
yourself is cool right and we kind of
get to this point where we realize that
you know sometime after we go through
school and then we go through the
process of unlearning everything that we
learned right
yeah there's two really crucial keys
there that I want to touch on first one
is the trauma that you're talking about
kind of the you know we've had we've had
we just finished a conversation with
Iran about it just this sort of the
childhood that that people go through
where parents are not always just
blissful angels throughout developing a
child into the world and because of that
we accrue some sort of traumas that then
we carry on through the later parts of
our life that then it
we don't integrate well and if we don't
integrate well then we can't really be
our full self and we can also can't
really raise a child so that's the cycle
that's why I'm single because I'm a mess
I'm not gonna be a good daddy good
husband a good anything I am ruined good
that's what one of them is the trauma
and then doing our best to avoid as much
that or integrate it currently and avoid
as much to that move forward and then
the other one was a sense of agency we
are being told from every direction
possible what to do and then rare
do we get sort of the ability ourselves
to decide what we want to do what
fulfills us probably have the tools and
resources in front of us provided to do
that so yes so then there's that and now
I you know we had you know we had your
logo up a moment ago I want to want to
touch on this because the turtles your
spirit animal yeah and tell us why the
turtle is part of the logo wife's spirit
animal yeah so I've always felt very
connected to sea turtles and the more I
travel places you know I see that it's
part of every culture I'll go buy a sea
turtle you know wherever I go and you
know the realization that I really came
to is you know more than the surface
level of they're chill and they swim
with the current they don't really have
any enemies it's a reminder to me of how
grateful I am for my life because a lot
of these t2 sea turtles when they hatch
from the sand they instinctively know to
swim to the shore but they don't all
make it you know they get snapped up by
birds or crabs or whatever it might be
and so it's a reminder of how grateful I
am for my life because I'm one of the
turtles that made it to the shore so if
you look at the logo here the sand
represents remembering where you came
from the water represents having an
intention for the future mm-hmm but
really where the water in the sand meet
the shore that represents presence often
times in mindfulness and meditation
practice you'll hear that because
there's no third thing it's just where
the water and the sand meet and
fluctuates based on the tide so the
further that you get away from the shore
either in this direction towards the
sand that's like getting lost in the
trauma the self-doubt whatever sort of
negative things you have from your past
that you're holding on to and the
further that you get away from the shore
in the direction of the water that's
getting lost in the anxiety of the
future and so it's important to remember
where you came from and have an
intention for the future but really when
you are present that is where
when you have your happiness and in the
center that's the moonlight which is the
natural light that guides you to the
shore all of these sea turtles about 98%
of them or something like that are
buried at night so when they hatch they
use the moonlight to guide them to the
shore so that represents your intuition
and you know the the tagline don't worry
B you know of course gives credence to
don't worry be happy but it's written in
children's handwriting because children
innately they know what they're there
they're interested in they're really
present all the time whatever emotions
they're experiencing they like feel
those feelings right they let it pass
through them and then they're back to
their jolly old selves right they're as
close to like being a human as you can
be like right away all right and then
over time we kind of conditioned them
into like these different ways of
believing things these belief structures
you know this one idea of success and
how to be in the world and they lose
sense of themselves over time and you
know whether or not they actually have
agency is up to that ultimately they can
make that decision I'm really excited to
talk about conditioning with you let's
let's
what's wander ourselves over to
conditioning in a moment because we the
the the this actually had a lot of
detail and thought to it and I really
appreciated that and it's there's the
sand there's the water there's the
moonlight there's the the balance
there's the child hand like handwriting
there's like you said this present the
moment of presence for every single
child it's just it's so human to be
right there in the present they're never
they're rarely ever wondering whenever
you what do you want to be when you grow
up what
yes totally my menu right now that's
like--that's that's their thing in so
many ways and that's so interestingly
fascinating it really is childhood
presence and you know it's it's a
reminder to the parents like look you
have a lot to learn from these kids as
well right
everyone's a student and everyone is a
teacher one of the values of happy and
really it's about bringing an openness
and a curiosity and a beginner's mind to
things and even if you don't agree with
someone maybe you have something to
learn about yourself you know ultimately
I believe all education is
self-education because I could be
spouting the greatest wisdom to you but
if you have no way to connect it back to
yourself and your experience then you're
not going to remember it what good is it
to you oh yeah yeah so how does one be
themselves yeah
it's hard right and I can go into like
sort of that framework of you know how
how I think society functions right now
let's do it yeah look conditioning the
condition I think it's important to go
tonight and then we could talk about how
it is that you actually be yourself
through it so you know basically the way
that we're conditioned in our societies
were told you need to do something so
that you can have something and
eventually one day you can be something
and it's this perpetual carrot or stick
type of extrinsic motivation along the
ladder of success and what you think
success might look like and we kind of
do this
unconsciously right eat your dinner so
you can have dessert get good grades so
you can get into a good school get a job
so you can make money do well in that
job so you can get a promotion right and
it starts from this place of you are not
enough as a person to begin with and you
constantly need to strive towards
something in order to prove your worth
now I understand why we structured
things in that way because you know how
are we gonna get people to build the
sewer system without some sort of
extrinsic motivator
right you know maybe there was one
person who was really intrinsically
motivated to build the sewer system but
I don't think we had the like quite the
gang of people it needed to build it out
right so you needed some form of
extrinsic motivation to get to the point
that that we're at now I don't really
think that's quite as much the case
especially with a lot of these
exponential technologies that we're
working on towards the future and you
know if you look at a kid you know we
ask them what they want to be when they
grow up we don't even know what the jobs
of the future are so why are we why are
we asking them that question right you
know really is that what they say did
they say that when you ask them little
kids did they don't know what does
sometimes they say they know sometimes
they say they don't but that's a good
point is with the one kid that answers
listen exponential technology is
unpredictable okay I don't know what I
want to be when I grow up they're like
yeah I meant it more from the
perspective of like why are we asking
that question you know yeah I think
there are really two questions that we
want to ask here which is one what
problem do you want to solve what either
impacts you on a personal level that you
feel like you want to do something about
it or something that you're so like
innately curious about that you just
like have to keep thinking about it like
you you're like this is this is what I
really turns my mind on right so I guess
it's not two questions but really it's
what problem do you want to solve and it
goes down like sort of those two schools
of thought like this either affects me
on a personal level or I'm just innately
curious about it or the combination of
those two this this reminds me a lot of
hierarchy and the pressures the economic
and social pressures that push us to
want to strive for more on the hierarchy
something about it like you were saying
earlier is really powerful because it
motivates and inspires us to go and make
something of our time in this world yeah
but at the same time it doesn't really
help us realize that we are already
absolutely beautiful as we are right
when we are here on the earth
and then we have this process of wanting
to become better over time and work on
our sold you that that we're a perfectly
imperfect yeah yeah well I affair enough
that's just not the way it is I'm just
telling you right yeah it's also tough
to say give these absolutes these
binaries about being totally you know
everyone is beautiful well oh my god Ray
Ray Price I think everything's beautiful
I'll get back with you on that go back
to the sorry yeah and then and so then
some of the pressures yes they do propel
people forward I think that's actually
quite nice that we are propelled forward
through that but at the same time it
doesn't help so much with just our
ability to relax and be ourselves and
then also to really understand that we
are beautiful as we are and not that we
have to go through like you said we have
to go to do something to have something
to be something yeah yeah you know what
I what I say is like why even inspire to
be something in the future when you can
learn to be yourself from the present
yeah and to be yourself in the present
yeah can't get really good at that yeah
and you know going back to that
framework of do something so that you
can have something it's in many ways its
kind of wired through scarcity right
because like the earliest humans had to
do things so that they can have things
to survive right yeah they had to find
water and shelter and food right so like
in a way it is it is part of who we are
let that idea of doing something so that
you can have something and that's really
important because you would die if you
didn't have the water or the food yeah
totally so then that's the scarcity
poverty addiction these different sort
of
mentalities that drove us to want to
live and not suffer and then that's kind
of the pressures that drove us forward I
I those were important they still are
important they still are important yeah
yeah you know you need to have your base
needs met and in order for you to learn
how to be yourself and really start to
thrive but I want to get back to
scarcity for a second here because you
know one of the things that we say
especially a lot around here is
competition Spurs innovation yeah yeah
right and kind of you know it spurs
iteration which is a form of innovation
you know I made something slightly
better I optimized some function of this
and competition is inherently scarce
because if there's a winner then there's
definitely going to be a loser and I
think it's that sort of mindset that has
led us towards this path of
overconsumption and producing things
that people want and not necessarily
what they need and telling them that
they are lacking and that they do need
to have something in order to be
something right you know you look at all
the products and services that we have
now you know like by this weight loss
program so you can have it and
eventually you can look like this right
and this is what you need to look like
right this is what society tells you
that you should look like you know
social media again is designed this way
it is a reflection of our current state
of consciousness yeah that's right
that's right
that's what it's designed I don't
understand what's your problem in order
to win someone has to lose some will win
some will lose some of all to sing
yeah I'm just saying I'm just saying I H
a PPI you bet it is society is a
reflection of our consciousness and then
furthermore is the mentality is shifting
towards abundance the mentality is
shifting towards prosperity collective
prosperity deeper empathy yeah and this
is all fantastic and you know movements
like happy also like digital wellness
warriors like what you're working on
these are progressing us towards that
that mentality over time yeah so maybe
yeah let me let me let me let me finish
the the point of you know how we're
conditioned but really the way that I
operate from a place of abundance and
really the way that I intend to operate
happy yeah and digital well in this
warriors is you know if you're lucky
enough to get out of the cycle of doing
and having and be something you can be
something one day most of those people
realize that they're not happy and it's
because they don't want to be something
they want to be themselves and so really
the place that we want to operate from
is be yourself do things that align with
who you are and then almost as a side
effect of that or byproduct have more
than you can imagine for yourself based
on what you value as an individual right
it's not an outcome you know we like the
thinking outcomes a lot but we're
constantly evolving and we're growing as
people over time and so really the more
that you key into what it is that you
value as an individual and try to
incorporate more of that intentionally
into your life the more that you start
doing things that align with that and
over time you might think well that was
great and I learned so much now I want
to do this because now I have greater
awareness through this intentionality
that I've incorporated so the question
was how do you be yourself and before we
get there just on what you just said
that if we start from a mentality of
being yourself and then just doing what
you love what feels right for you what
you just what you fall in love with oh
you're passionate about and building
that into the world over time I totally
see how starting from a place of being
yourself can get you to a place of
abundance for yourself and for other
people around you I like that a lot
rather than sort of maybe like being
some thing so be yourself but also being
yourself with a goal or an intention of
like doing what you love and like what
you want because you can also get
trapped in a form of consumption and
whatnot yeah okay so let's talk about
being yourself yourself it's like
obviously way easier said than done
being yourself is hard right because I
think it starts from a place of loving
yourself first which is kind of how I
got down this path myself you know
originally it stemmed from watching my
niece play with an iPad and I was like I
love this being more than anything and
now she's getting sucked into a bunch of
sponsored content for products and I
thought I'm not okay with that
and in the process of having that
realization I was also like well if I
love this being so much how come I don't
love myself like that mm-hmm
and that that really helped me start
getting down this path and being more
intentional with incorporating more of
what I want right not just being a
people pleaser all the time and doing
things so that I can have things so yeah
it starts from a place of self-love but
you know going back to trauma
it requires either coping with that
trauma that you have healing from it in
some way or using it maybe as a tool to
help other people by sharing your
stories and being vulnerable I would say
that it also in some ways requires
physically healing your body you know we
get aches and pains all the time that
are you know little distractions but
really they're they're bits of
information telling us hey I need some
love here like I need to you know work
on my shoulder this thing is really
aching me right here your body has this
inherent wisdom and it's also telling
you how you can be more of yourself and
be more open and you know a lot of the
technology we have now gets us kind of
hunching like that we're at
right and we're blocking ourselves off
to a lot of things mm-hmm
and so you know big focus of mine has
been on posture and like really healing
through all the like tension that I have
my body I used to have a pinched nerve
in my shoulder one in the back of my
knee to the point where like my leg
would go numb if I was sitting in the
wrong position or you know my whole arm
would go numb for a few seconds and have
to like shake it back into feeling that
was it telling me like this needs to be
addressed right away
and so I did I focused a lot of time
just on physically healing mentally
healing emotionally healing and
spiritually healing and nobody saying
that you have to do all this now right
you start small right start start with
doing little things that are really
achievable little intentional habits
that you can create it still gives you
the instant gratification that you're
looking for is this something that
parents are really in charge in should
be focused on helping their children
form these little small habits they
should be focused on forming it for
themselves first and yet once they
achieve that for themselves then they
can be that role model for the kids and
then help their kids also yeah and don't
tell them what to do and when to do it
all the time that's what they do they
want to teach them the [ __ ] that
they believe they bought into be the
same thing get three jobs I don't care
what you do for a living get three job
totally and you know look at the place
that we're in now right um it's it's
clearly no longer sustainable for our
own individual well-being or our
collective well-being or the well-being
of this planet right
and you know so many people are unhappy
because they're forcing themselves
to do things that are not fun right and
they don't enjoy a full third of our
lives for some people is just not fun no
half of our waking hours you only get 16
waking hours can you imagine spending it
doing something you hate look yeah yeah
that in itself is the problem it is but
even in doing those things that you you
hate you can still in many cases be more
intentional about how you are able to
throw in little bits of yourself into
that work you know but then we really
need the long term transition for
ourselves into something of eight hours
a day that we love totally completely
agree you know my thinking behind this
is you know right now capitalism and
technology's incentives are
fundamentally misaligned with our
well-being and how would you fix that
well I believe we have the power to
realign those incentives by being
intentional about prioritizing our own
well-being and taking care of those that
we love okay I think I finally am
getting it all connected took me a
little while to get it all connected
yeah okay so actually the first key of
the whole conversation that we've been
having the last couple of hours is the
word intention yeah that's the big thing
and then I'll let you get to the
definition in a moment actually give me
the definition first in the oil where I
went where I want to go with yeah and I
have another point that I want to add as
well but I heard a great definition
which is intention is the pervasive
force that guides our awareness yes I
love that
yeah I love that so okay so we have this
intention and then we'll get to what you
want to say after that this pervasive
force that guides our awareness and then
the intention the first form of
intention must be at a mirror
and then we look at ourselves and then
we intend to be ourselves our love our
care towards ourselves that bodywork
that you were talking about for your
pinched nerves human can't function with
pinched nerves you have to literally
take time off of life so that you can
focus on your body so you can keep
living and then when you look at
yourself and you see parts of yourself
that you want to you know maybe you know
package away integrate some of your
traumas you know work on those
experience it's okay so the first
intentionality is mirror and then the
intentionality becomes what can I do for
bring value of maybe to the community or
towards my kids right so then that's
kind of the second phase of things so an
intentionality goes from intention with
me intention with my community and
children and then I'm the role model and
then they and then I work with them
which then they are their own role
models and whatnot as well yeah yeah
exactly and yeah you you got to start
with the inner work in order to inform
the outer work yeah right I love your
definition of intention and it's not
mine
but yes I love that one too yeah we
stand on the shoulders of giants where
did you where were you going to go after
intention you had another thing you
wanted yeah I wanted to quickly touch on
the well-being of us taking care of our
well-being you know mm-hmm if we want
those systems to support it create
products and services that are in
support of our well-being then we have
to build the demand for it by living and
taking better care of ourselves right
and we've seen some of this start to
happen you know with food for instance
right there's a reason that we have
vegan and vegetarian options at
restaurants there's a reason that
Walmart is now the largest distributor
of organic food in the world Wow right
yeah and that doesn't mean there aren't
other kinds of ethical questions and
concerns raised there like whether or
not that food is being sustainably
produced on the land right it just means
that it does have pesticides there all
progress there also one of the
world's largest employers after the US
and Chinese military stand then Walmart
has I believe somewhere around like two
million total employees across the world
yeah yeah we don't need to get too far
down that path because there's another
bunch of ethical questions and concerns
that we could raise their intentionality
but yes you know the point the point
being you know I believe that parents
are the biggest agents of change whether
or not they recognize it yet the biggest
problem which means that they're the
biggest opportunity for solutions yeah
you know they're involved in the
education system they're involved in the
workplace where they spend their money
is really impactful
whether it's capitalism or philanthropy
people vote with their dollars right
people vote every day and parents are
also the most intrinsically motivated
you know they want to make sure their
kids have it better than they do and
while they might be ill informed or
misguided in doing that they do still
want the best for their kids and I do
believe that unconditional love is the
greatest motivator that we have again
that's how I I got down this path myself
and when it comes to parenting and
well-being is so intersectional it's
it's at the intersection of all these
other movements that already exists it
is a conscious leadership it is the
environment it is women's rights it's
social justice its mindfulness its
emotional intelligence its visual
intelligence its community engagement
it's all the things right it's it's
connected to all those things and so my
message again going back to abundance is
and you know I see this a lot especially
in the nonprofit sector and I was
talking about competition you know we're
all competing for the scarce amount of
resources which is just bizarre
especially in the nonprofit world
because we're all ultimately trying to
achieve collective well-being and
building communities that are diverse
and equitable and inclusive and my
message is hey let's all organize our
a message of our well-being and let's
work together and make this pie way
bigger because the resources are out
there it's just that nobody in the
philanthropic sector wants to give money
to something that might fail right you
know they want something with like a
clear ROI to it right if I can donate a
hundred million dollars and put my name
on a building at a college you know my
kids can go to that College I can cherry
pick whatever students I want to come
work for me you know I can I can push my
agenda in some way and I did something
good for Humanity
you know conscious clean boom clear ROI
check check check check check right you
know whereas when it comes to social
change it's not so clear right and it's
hard to know exactly what is happening
and how much impact it's happened is
happening and so you know the way I look
at it when it comes to something like
happy is you know if we're looking to
build an ecosystem that's working
towards our well-being
you know I've planted this happy seed in
the ground and I know at some point it's
gonna grow into the most magnificent
happy tree it's gonna give shade and
oxygen and it's kind of a bunch of
delicious fruits on it and I know that
those roots are gonna share nutrients
with all the other things in the
ecosystem right but when someone looks
at it they go yeah maybe there's like a
little sprout or something there I guess
right but what they don't see is this
massive web of roots that we've created
underneath the ground that's connected
to everything in the ecosystem right the
mycelium yeah right which is where
everything grows from right and it
judges the health of the ecosystem and
so you know I think in our focusing on
what is objective what can you quantify
what can you measure what metrics are
you following we have lost sight of what
is subjective but also really important
you know how how am I going to measure
art or beauty or inspiration or mad
nation or storytelling or you know so
many of these things that make us
fundamentally human right it doesn't
mean we can't measure them but it's
really hard to do it oh man I love how
deeply studied you are in this and also
how you are you're starting from a pro
first principles view of things which is
intentionality and then that builds into
what happy is and what and what digital
wellness is I love it okay so so what
wat walk us through this because I know
that I know that you know you said that
this is gonna take a little longer to
unpack then than you think but I still
think it's important to talk about give
us the juice and sauce analogy it is
very much connected to all of this this
is a something I've been workshopping
with people recently and you know I'm
someone the way that my mind works is I
take a bunch of things and I'm like oh
that's connected to this and that's
connected to this yeah and then my mind
starts weaving it into this tapestry of
ideas to tell a story with so juice and
sauce oh man I won't get into the whole
thing because you can I think explained
pretty much anything in terms of juice
and sauce but the way I got down this
line of thinking to begin with is I
overheard this video playing in the
background this guy said you want to
have the sauce and not the juice and I
went whoa that resonated with me why why
did that hit me so hard right and
whenever that happens to me that's like
my inner wisdom telling me like you need
to inquire further about this you need
to think about this more and I'm like
okay well how is juice made well juice
is taking something external to yourself
sucking the resources out of it
typically you're leaving some waste
behind and you use that to give you a
temporary boost of some sort so you
think about how juice comes up in our
culture you know taking steroids is
juicing you know I got to get my phone
some juice really juiced about this
event we have coming
you know or you know something I've
heard with kids my age that look look at
that girl she's juicy right I care about
this one aspect of her that's giving me
this temporary satisfaction and not the
whole being and this all ties to the
instant gratification that we've been
talking about sauce on the other hand is
this constructive process by what you're
taking all of these different
ingredients you got to give them time to
start melding together you got to be
really patient when making a good sauce
and I would also say that all the best
sauces are made with love and maybe you
have a memory of your grandma sauce or a
sauce that your mom made right it's like
such a vivid memory associated to it
right which is really difficult to
quantify and measure right now you think
about how sauce comes up in our culture
someone's secret secret sauce or their
special sauce right something we hear
all the time right that's their thing
that makes them unique and nobody can
take that from them and maybe it's their
competitive advantage and you know
someone who's saucy kind of has their
own sass about them and you can also get
sauce right with your friends go out you
get sauce I would say that's like
getting loose but you can also get lost
in the sauce and that's it's important
right there's a fine line and balance
there and that's when you maybe get a
little too egocentric or full of
yourself too drunk whatever it might be
and you end up with a plate full of
sauce right nobody wants to eat a plate
full of sauce now I would say there's
some people who don't really learn their
lesson right they keep getting lost and
they use bread to mop it up right they
use money to clean up their mess which I
would say still leaves a sticky
situation behind I think most people
kind of try to figure out what's what's
the right amount of sauce here let me
start figuring this out I want to make
sure this is a cohesive dish that people
are going to enjoy right I want to make
sure there's substance beneath the sauce
it's not all just sauce everywhere now
you know I think I will get into this
part of it I'm just like trying to think
of how much I want to get into keep
going it's really good it's a good sauce
right and what I find and it's really
meta in this way right the more that I
share it with people the more they start
adding their own ingredients into it and
they're like oh and that connects to
this and I'm like yes exactly thank you
right and over time that sauce becomes
more rich and savory and complex right
and every time I share it with someone
who becomes a new sauce in a certain way
now there's some people here who try to
take a shortcut to making sauce you know
they either don't want to put the time
and energy into it they're looking for
something cheap and fast maybe they
don't know how to put love into it all
right and so they compensate by putting
in a ton of salt and you know what I
would say is that these people are all
the haters out there making salty sauces
right lots of haters with salty sauces
out there and if you're someone who's
grown up around a bunch of salty sauces
you're gonna think that's what sauce
tastes like right you're not gonna know
any better and you know you're thinking
I'm thirsty and be hydrated from all the
salt I want juice and so it perpetuates
the cycle of people craving juice
instead of figuring out how to make a
really good sauce right now we can help
these people this is what we're doing
now we're focusing on how we can help
people make sauce and we got to show
them what really good sauces that are
made with love taste like like
simulation series right like happy like
digital wellness warriors right and that
inspires them to start working on their
own sauce they go I didn't know you can
make sauce this good this is amazing I
want to work on my own sauce right but
making sauce is really hard also and I
think that's where a lot of people get
held up you're gonna fail a bunch of
times making your sauce I'm sure we've
both failed tons of times along this
path yeah full circles that making your
sauce is being yourself yes
exactly so you know it's also to the
point now where we have so many
ingredients to make sauce with like you
open the cover you're like I don't even
know where to begin this is overwhelming
I have this paradox of choice right and
so you're going I'll just go for the
easy thing I'm just gonna have some
juice I don't want to make sauce right
now all right it becomes so much easier
to just have some juice that's when you
open up that Facebook or Instagram apps
with your app instead of writing or
drawing or making a video or writing up
something that right inspires you or
calling a friend you haven't heard from
the thank you Ron yeah no that's that's
good that's good
so what what does this mean there's a
big what are those what are they give
the big guillotine comes down to chops
your body in half so yeah back to life
yeah right I want to make this point
which is even once you've figured out
what your sauces not everyone's gonna
like it right does everyone love
simulation series no no right does
everyone love happy no no I mean my
intention is for everyone to love it but
I know that's not gonna be the case
interesting so your sauce will you know
attract maybe one person then 10 then
100 or whatever and you might just stick
out 100 and be done right sometimes it
might get a million and you might be
great that'd be great times people will
add ingredients to the sauce yeah
exactly
so thank you yeah but again it's being
yourself your sauces yourself is
yourself right and find your sauce
instead of find your path yeah follow
your sauce follow your sauce so you know
you don't just make one sauce - right
like you you make different sauces given
the situation that you're in
microwaves a sauce and different well
those words is the sauce right culture
is sauce music that you make culture
seems to have an absurd amount of
ingredients in the sauce right now yeah
and there's a lot of salt a lot of that
short term yeah totally
yeah I really see how this yeah analogy
can be yeah applicable yeah I like it
first time I've heard of it it's an
analogy because I think I came up with I
mean somebody inspired me with their own
sauce that they created to get down this
rabbit hole of my mind
right and to be open to sharing it with
everyone right and you smell that sauce
you're like that's good it's all good I
want some more of it yeah so you want
your sauce to be so good that you
yourself feel like you are being
yourself and also that that you're
working on making yourselves better over
time and that you're working on right on
helping other people with their sauces
yeah ridiculous totally and I want to
get to this point that I didn't finish
making which is it's okay that not
everyone loves your sauce right what
matters is that you love your sauce and
you're not the only person who loves
your sauce because then you would be
lost in your own sauce so so so that's
that's a good point so you might you
might be there's a couple things here so
if your sauce is doing something harmful
to society then that's not good it's not
sick less toxic sauce yeah if your sauce
is only loved by yourself it might be
narcissistic sauce but it also might be
like a 1% like a copernicus sauce like
you might be thinking of something
that's so counterculture that nobody
else is thinking about it and so it
might take a really long time for you to
get your first follower your first yes
I'm like yes totally yeah so sometimes
having your own sauce that nobody else
quite understands their likes yet it
just potentially means that it'll take a
little more time for people to totally
but you still have to give the
invitation for people to try your sauce
made with love totally right
and if people are like to the right
people because a lot of people that are
trying your sauce may in fact spit it
back at your face and actually they they
might they might decrease your in your
motivation to continue working on your
sauce because of that process so okay
this is kind of the whole the the golden
information of the or the gold nugget or
the nuggets of wisdom that the things
that you carry around with yourself that
are profound to you and then if you go
and say them to the wrong person the
person will just spit the wisdom in your
face and say that it's not profound or
important to you whereas if you share it
with someone else that actually gets you
a lot of that a lot of times this
happens after maybe you go on a profound
meditation experience and then you go
and speak to someone that absolutely
hates meditation about it and then there
and then there then they just they do
you take everything you said and they
push it down versus if you talk to them
that also meditates they'll be like whoa
that was interesting about it how it
felt for you this is how it felt for me
and then it becomes a deeper
conversation yeah totally you know what
I would say is that person is salty and
really what they're looking for is Jesus
they don't want sauce right so so okay
we can also view we can also view the
juice as the short-term dopaminergic
hijacking of attention and reward and
that whole economy of thought and then
the sauce is the long term the
prefrontal cortex the structuring of
maybe your sauce over time totally yeah
and I think it's important to to mention
then that juice is still so incredibly
important you actually need juice in
order to make sauce
nobody is born with sauce you need juice
to make sauce tell us about that
yeah so what I say is you know you might
be born with ingredients but you're not
born with sauce it takes consuming lots
of juice mm-hmm
being inspired by different sauces made
with love and also trying a bunch of
salty sauces that ultimately help you
figure out what your
it's interesting right and on a very
practical level you still need
electricity or gas from your stove in
order to make sauce right that's a form
of juice it's energy right and what we
want is to get to the point where we
have 100% renewable clean juice yeah we
don't have that yet yeah so juice is
still important you need juice yeah but
you want to find juices that are in
service of your sauce right that's
pretty good yeah and so you know you
like it you want to find juices that are
worth the squeeze right in other words
yeah and the this is this has been so
interesting yeah it's really good to
hear new analogies that are applicable
across one of the most important aspects
of being human which is being yourself
finding your sauce your passion bringing
that to the world
yeah what I would say is like really the
because I could go on and on about this
but I want to wrap up ultimately what
you want is to be a saucier where you
know what a saucier is it's like a
connoisseur of sauces kind of it's like
you know they have them in French
restaurants a lot they're the person who
makes all the sauces the salad dressings
the roux bases for stews and things like
that soups wow you're that in your
previous life one of them neighbor
Berkshire you are one of those person
yeah yeah and that's like arguably the
most important thing right that's where
all the flavor comes from and so what
that means is not only do you have your
sauce and it's amazing right but you're
really cultured and you know how to make
a bunch of other really amazing sauces
that are made with love and like most
importantly you can take the ingredients
that you get in any situation and still
make a good sauce out of it right you
get like a mystery basket of ingredients
and you're like well I guess I'm gonna
make sauce right that's that's the only
thing I can do and I think the ultimate
the ultimate goal and aspiration here
again I don't like to think in terms of
like
to MIT outcomes but this is if I had one
this would be it right which is to be a
master saucier you are so good that you
can now teach other people to make sauce
right and they still have to make it but
you can help them total you can help
them yeah climb up the mountain you can
always walk up with someone that's
walked up the mountain before exactly
yeah I like that that's good saucier
yeah one yes so that's interesting so
then you can get really good at a bunch
of different sauces not only of your own
but tasting others helping people maybe
with the amount of salts and their
sauces
yeah maybe helping people find out what
their sauces are with the right
ingredients using cleaner juices Oh
interesting the jute the clean juices
yeah maybe the clean juice is clean
energy yeah that's that's that's a good
way to think about it yeah if you're if
you're you know if you're if you're you
know if you're putting an IV in of
McDonald's or putting an IV in of
Instagram for its for tons of hours
every single day that is that's poor
quality energy and that means that's
gonna be a poor quality sauce but if you
put in clean energy maybe you put in
working out maybe you put in writing
poetry or music or whatever you
gratitude practice gratitude and
meditation yeah sure then then that that
IV will be lead to really powerful
juices yeah it's very herbal sorrel
sauce that sauces wow it's so good yeah
that ended up that ended up being as
profound as I thought it was gonna be
actually I I knew from when I started
talking about it that like you know in
order to actually have an analogy or
metaphor that is that is so comprehend
because it's such a it's such a daily
thing but also at the same time it is
such and deep-rooted instinct within
ourselves of to find that we are our
sauce okay so yeah you seem like you
have another thing you want to say I
have another analogy which is pretty
brief okay but I want to share it brief
yes on parenting okay go ahead
so is this philosophy called the
gardener and the carpenter style of
parenting and what we see now is there's
lots of carp in planting the seeds
instead of hammering yeah and in a way
yes right
the carpenter like that yeah planting
the seeds instead of hammering the nails
right yeah look yeah we need more
farmers and less right totally totally
and you know there's that quote right
which is like if the only tool you have
is a Hammer Every Problem begins to look
like a nail yep right so yeah you think
about what a carpenter's job is they
have a vision for this house that they
want to build
they're very meticulous about executing
on that vision they make a blueprint
they measure twice and cut once they can
control every single variable and
they're thinking once I finish building
this house I'm gonna be so happy
I'll have built this thing that I
envisioned right yeah and what ends up
happening is typically one of two things
they build the house and doesn't turn
out quite the way they wanted it and
they're disappointed in the house that
they built or they built the house and
that's all it is it's a house and not a
home right the foundation isn't rooted
in anything right and carpentry is
something that is human-made it's
naturally going to be imperfect
right yeah we're as gardeners and they
plant a seed in the ground and in the
case of a parent you don't even know
what the seeds gonna grow into it's an
anonymous to seed that you planted right
and you want to create the environment
for that seed to flourish right make
sure it's getting plenty of water and
nutrients and sunlight you also want to
prune some of the leaves in the branches
but from a place of love and not out of
fear right for the the future growth and
flourishing of this plant and you also
have to understand that there's so many
things that are out of your control and
I think this is something that parents
struggle with a lot is that you can't
control everything
all right and you know you know at the
end of the day you can't control the
weather there's gonna be Gophers
underneath the ground you got all these
roots that are sharing nutrients with
all the other plants around it
some of them are good and some of them
are bad right so ultimately what's more
important than you tending to your
individual plant is the ecosystem right
the community is ultimately what's the
most important because that's what's
influencing them when you're not there
you have to take care of your own sauce
your own seed in the community because
your node impacts the other nodes yeah
yeah Wow
good stuff good stuff I'm so happy right
now with an i mission yeah mission
accomplished yeah do that again I missed
I hate myself I was never born I wanted
to be a janitor let's work on that
together Ron I have so much sauce to
share and I want to share it with you
like me and being miserable don't worry
about it all right yeah well you can
give you a hug at the window I'm with a
couple the quickie is on the way out
we'd like to ask these questions on the
show we're curious what your thoughts
are yeah do you think we're alone in the
cosmos oh that's really hard I think
there are just things that we are
enabled to perceive with our senses Yeah
right
I think there are many layers of
consciousness and you know maybe some
kids have access to some of these things
and we just don't know because we
conditioned them into like this is our
perception of things so - right and this
is what you need to think and this is
what you believe right so what was it
you the one the one the one what was it
a grandmaster chess player something
said that I can train my kids to become
the world's best chess players I can
train them to become the world's best
pickpocketers I can train them to become
whatever you can train a child's mind to
become absolutely anything and so when
you said that I was thinking what could
you be trained a child to become the
absolute
best like meditator or consciousness
Explorer or ability to go past the third
dimension into whatever else exists out
there anyway continue on the cosmos yes
yeah well to add on to your point right
there it's um you know it starts off
maybe from a place of extrinsic
motivation you can train them through
extrinsic motivation but ultimately they
have to be intrinsically motivated to
continue that path absolutely yeah right
so yes they at their own will right
deciding that this is core to Who I am
and I have agency I'm gonna decide to do
this you can go down this path but ya
going back to to the cosmos yeah you
know I'm I'm a a believer in in the
divine right there is something greater
than us that created this right Nate
going back to the Gardner analogy nature
is divine and that's why it works right
it's like the most intelligent design
that exists right yeah
you look at your body you look at your
mind that's all part of nature you look
at the trees and the grass and the
mycelium and the animals and the
waterfalls and the oceans and the moon
and right yeah yeah all of it yeah it's
the most intelligent design ever yeah
yeah so what is that thing above because
then we ask you know if you think we're
in a simulation so what is that thing
that is above what is that
man I I don't have I don't have the
answers right of course what are you
what do you think I'm someone who's
committed to asking more of those
questions but for you that's why we
asked questions on the show yeah we
don't have answers
I don't know right and I think part of
life is everybody hey you want juice
right I got juice right yeah yeah right
whereas you know something like this is
this is uncertain it isn't and so much
of it requires faith and belief and in
that thing that is much bigger than
yourself do you think this is base
reality or do you think
the ocean man I really don't know I
really don't know I think you're on the
fence yeah I am I'm really on the fence
I don't good for you yeah well he needs
to be for all the things that he
discusses and he's working on and
talking about he can't have any answer
to these yeah so that's why I'm like huh
I I understand that school of thought it
makes sense to me and you know I'm you
know that mate leaves me the question of
like why do we have deja vu right I love
how you said that yeah right yeah I do I
know you
yeah that's another thing when I say you
look familiar
there is a familiarity you know which
beyond this I don't want to take the
show in another direction we bring with
us where aren't we're already at an hour
all right I'm just saying yeah there's
we met before man
yeah everything that we're talking about
some of them the examples that you've
shown me in your creative expression are
juice I understand them too much to just
dismiss out coincidence so let's let's
end the show yeah really looks through
last question what do you thinks the
most beautiful thing in the world home
in whatever sense that is to you you
know I think of you know if I if I'm
going to change the way the education
system works right I want to reframe the
narrative around what homeschooling is
because what are all the things that you
call home or would like to call home
well your heart is your home your body's
your home relationships that you have
with other people are home your
residence hopefully is your home your
community again hopefully earth is your
home right so the the schooling that we
need to give is helping people feel like
they're at home what no matter what
place or environment that they're in
right so what is homework right homework
is the inner work in outer work that you
have to do to feel like you're at home
in all of these places right so the most
beautiful thing is
feeling that sense of home love it
Wow intention parenting intentionally
helping awesome parents parents
intentionally yeah yeah there's the
wellness did you know wellness if we
didn't have a ton of time to get em to
attend definitely make mix that in with
the with the happy and also with some of
the juice for sauce yeah that was really
powerful analogy that we spent a lot of
time on I'm really happy Gaby what a
freaking pleasure it's been having you
on the show
thank you really appreciate it so so
much yeah thank you and keep up the good
work we are counting on you we're
lifting me up this is part of the
ecosystem yeah yeah right we're all
sharing nutrients with one another yeah
exactly
we're crafting our sauces at the
crafting our sauces we want technology
that doesn't just give us juice we want
technology that helps us make sauce
right it totally depends on what those
IVs are that we put in what the energy
that we put in is the IV can be a little
scary it's like what energy we put in
would ya just make an energy juice in
yeah yeah okay thank you everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it let
us know what you think of the episode in
the comments let us know what were some
cool talking points what you want to
expand on how you want to expand on the
sauce juice analogy unhappy on all these
different things also go and create go
and manifest your destiny into the world
go and build go create that sauce thank
you to gabby for joining us thank you to
ron for producing and directing much
love to you all we will see you soon
[Music]
[Music]